on a eu hier des chiffres concernant les
taux de retards des trains sont les
chiffres 2018
mais ils montrent que la situation
s'aggrave plus tôt regardez ce graphique
il vous montre un petit peu quels
étaient les retards des trains cinq ans
avant et qu'est-ce qui était en 2018
alors vous avez les trains de région les
ter où il ya à peu près 10% en train en
retard et on monte à 17% ou au dessus
pour les trains intercités et pour les
tgv alors ses calculs et de la façon
suivante en gros s'il ya plus de cinq
minutes de retard pour des courts
trajets c'est à dire moins d'une heure
trente s'est considéré comme en retard
et ensuite on monte à 10 minutes 15
minutes en fonction de la durée du
trajet entre alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire parce que la situation s'arrange
pas est-ce qu'il faut sanctionner la
sncf alors les sanctions existent déjà
théoriquement notamment à travers un
système de bonus malus qui est mis en
place par les régions notamment en ile
de france je parle sous contrôle de
maxime d'égailler de véraison président
de la commission des finances de la
région ile-de-france alors votre
présidence justement valérie pécresse
elle trouve qu'il faudrait peut-être
mettre un peu plus de 2 de bonus et
surtout de malus pour essayer de faire
améliorer le comportement de la sncf
alors c'est vous le spécialiste de
sujets peut-être comme élu régional on
rappelle que les régions contribuent
très largement au financement des ter
oui alors il ya des contrats de
performance vous l'avez dit qu'ils
faut que les régions et d'ailleurs
depuis qu'elles ont pris la
responsabilité pour la région ile de
france
depuis quelques années des transports
ont objectivement une gestion plus tôt
proactive
de l'organisation des mobilités c'est
efficace ou pas quand vous avez les
amendes alors c'est efficace sauf que
enfin c'est efficace c'est comme quand
vous donnez une sanction est ce que ça
veut dire que le lendemain le train
arrivera peu en retard parce que vous
lui avez tapé sur les rails je ne suis
pas certain et donc il faut le faire
pour mettre en responsabilité les
opérateurs mais c'est une question plus
globale m'excuserai de l'évoquer mais
c'est que le sujet qui nous est posée
c'est aujourd'hui développement des
transports publics des infrastructures
ferroviaires
il ya eu une vraie erreur nationale
il ya maintenant plus de 20 ans qui a
été de favoriser le tgv par rapport au
transport de proximité on en paye encore
les pots cassés
aujourd'hui donc fouet à la lgv sont en
retard il faut réorienter les transports
il faut réorienter les crédits et
delémont mais il me semble que on
parlait tout à l'heure des solutions d
parier je crois de ceux qui se
mobilisent sur le climat qui est bon
effectivement quelquefois porte une
cause avant de porter des revendications
il me semble que les financements on
dirait on pour l'amélioration des
transports ça devrait être ça s'inscrit
totalement dans le changement
de notre économie c'est sur toi et donc
on pourrait imaginer que les
investissements en matière de transport
tu sortes des 3% du critère de
maastricht pour il faudrait qu'on mette
les investissements qu'ils aillent en
face des besoins qui sont les nôtres à
tous en fait le problème vient du
l'entretien du réseau vous l'avez
souligné les tgv sont en sus en retard
mais c'est parce que les tgv utilise en
partie le réseau en fait je dise pas que
les grands lignes qui ont été
construites depuis dans les années 80 il
utilise l'ensemble du réseau géo cité le
rapport spinetta vous vous souvenez
c'est le rapport qui préconise et de
fermer les petites lignes
donc c'est pas un rapport de bolchévique
que je vous cite oui le réseau
ferroviaire français a fait l'objet d'un
sous investissement massif dans la
maintenance depuis la fin des années 70
en raison d'arbitrages budgétaires qui
ont favorisé le développement du réseau
et la construction des lignes de tgv au
détriment du réseau existant
donc on a alors un premier facteur est
ensuite on a eu les grèves pour le
restant de la semaine cf qui ont qui ont
causé des retards et des annulations de
trains
et en plus il ya des intempéries cette
année là mais en fait j'ai envie de vous
dire que la question des sanctions
c'est comme si je vous disais de faire
le figure avec deux fois moins de
journalistes et que le lendemain je
disais il ya les photographes donc je
vais vous taper sur les doigts
ça me paraît pas forcément très efficace
quoi vous en pensez quoi
le coussin ce qu'on dit de l'autre côté
de la table c'est assez classiquement
c'est un problème de manque de moyens en
partie seulement non pas du tout mais ça
fait des années
ça fait des années que j'écris sur la
sncf gdf dame au bureau des piles de
rapport spinetta cour des comptes il y
en a plusieurs assemblée sénat
j'en passe européen
aussi qu'ils font des comparaisons faut
pas oublier que l'asm reçoit au dessus
de 13 milliards d'euros par an de la
part de l'état des collectivités locales
et que ça coûte pas cher ça coûte très
cher ya pas vraiment de contrôle et si
elle contrôle aussi à des punitions ou
des combos l'audit là c'est le
contribuable qui paie nous sommes là et
ça c'est pas du tout efficace pourtant
elle investit à l'étranger et elle a
beaucoup plus d'employés que ses
concurrentes que deutsche bahn que
d'autres d'autres compagnies
ferroviaires le rapport spirit a dit
très bien qu'il ya un
sous-investissement investissements ne
pas qu'il n'ya pas d'argent qui a été
orientée qui l'accord interne werber les
tgv de son bilan pour ce soit les
réseaux les réseaux régionaux sont ville
être en vie sous région sont vides
c'est ça le sait ça ce que ça change et
là c'est bien mais ça ce que ça change
beaucoup aujourd'hui ça change beaucoup
vas-y c'est ce que dit le rapport c'est
cela même s'il ya des facilités vers les
terres qui sont vides tout simplement
donc il faut quand même à prendre des
décisions ne pas faire payer les
contribuables deux ou trois ou quatre
fois la biètre twitter vous considérez à
75 pour ça qu'il faut sanctionner la
sncf pour les retards et voici quelques
commentaires en vrac vole pas eu qui dit
il ya surtout un manque d'entretien
général brownie tôt lui relativise pour
avoir pris le train à l'étranger j'ai du
mal à plaindre de la sncf
nicole nous dit comme certains les
intervenants autour de ce plateau
le problème c'est qu'on a tout misé sur
le tgv en laissant tomber les lignes
classiques
et puis yoann il y a de moins en moins
de cheminots ah bon et de plus en plus
de sous traitants qui ne font pas bien
leur travail
jenny bastié c'est pas comme si comme
observatrice comme usagère êtes vous
satisfaite
non évidemment je suis pas satisfaite et
je pense qu'il ya un problème
au delà du retard un problème de prix
aussi c'étaient les prix explosent et
moi qui retourne souvent don sud ouest
natal
je privilégie le train parce que c'est
plus écolo mais c'est souvent plus cher
que l'avion
c'est à dire que prendre le train pour
rentrer pour se déplacer en france est
plus cher que l'avion ce qui est une
aberration il me semble dans une époque
les nations à une époque pour aller à
toulouse par exemple
[Musique]
et je trouve qu'à une époque où on nous
parle sans cesse d'écologie neissen
nécessité de transition écologique ce
n'est pas normal ça devrait ça devrait
être moins cher le train que l'avion
alors je ne sais pas s'il faut casser
les prix des retards augmenter le prix
de l'avion justement taxes en kérosène
par exemple parce qu'on sait pas du tout
non mais en tout cas pour les vols
intérieurs pour les vols intérieurs je
n'aurais pas c'est pas normal mais ça ne
me paraît pas normal positif réalité un
point d'accord sur le kérosène cd je
trouvais un premier pas quand même
comparer avec l'exemple moi j'ai pris le
train j'ai beaucoup pris le train en
grande bretagne lui et trinque à une
cinq fois plus cher que dans le reste de
l'europe et la qualité du service est
déplorable donc c'était j'avais
développé depuis longtemps désolé je le
prends ça comme ça ceux ci nationale ter
britannique déjà plusieurs compagnies
d'ailleurs que ça n'occupe très très
bien il est d'ailleurs un classement
européen ils sont dans les trois
premiers c'est pas la vie de bree tanner
les les français sont des et même
peut-être juste pour essayer un peu
d'ouvrir le débat ne sont que le la
question c'est qu'il faut enfin moi je
trouve qu'on est dans des contradictions
et dans des injonctions contradictoires
d'ailleurs bien souvent auprès des
pouvoirs publics comme auprès des
citoyens c'est qu'on peut pas expliquer
qu'on va changer de modèle économique
qu'il faut se déplacer de manière
différente qui a des enjeux
d'aménagement du territoire et ne pas
avoir de stratégie de développement de
mobali de mobilité moins polluantes
or ces dernières années la seule
discussion qu'on a eue ça veut pas dire
qu'il ya pas d amélioration à voir y
compris dans le fonctionnement des ag
dans la de la gestion j'ai pas de
difficulté que ça mais on a passé notre
temps à expliquer qu'il fallait réduire
les coûts on a abandonné une partie du
ferroviaire et logistique parce que on
pour des questions de deux coups de
courten de gestion tout court terme et
et et pourtant le discours vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure vous avez dit que
quand vous ouvriez la télé ont pas
toujours des problématiques thématiques
et ben c'est problématique climatique
s'est éteint il faut qu'on change de
modèle la ja il ya quelque chose qui
cloche donc si on décide véritablement
de changer d'hôtel on s'y met les moyens
je parle encore de moyens mais il me
semble que nos sommes animés - m en plus
on l'adossé une vraie stratégie et moi
je termine par une ultime proposition en
changeant de modèles en plus peut-être
mettre un peu moins d'argent sur les
régimes spéciaux de retraite des
cheminots qui comme ça trois gros un peu
plus longtemps et un peu plus sur le
réseau
mais ce n'est qu'un point de vue voilà
c'est fini pour ce soir merci beaucoup
nous ne serons pas là lundi pour cause
de lundi de pâques mais nous revenons
mardi et d'ici là je voyais ce pack à
tous bonsoir
[Musique]